[Musique]
dans ce village ce n'est pas la religion
qui impose aux femmes d'être voilée mais
uniquement le respect des hommes qui les
entourent
l'émancipation est un parcours de longue
haleine pour les femmes indiennes
surtout en régions rurales comme ici en
ou tard pradesh où les basses castes
sont majoritaires quel est votre nom je
n'ai pas de nom elle n'a pas de nom à
goody je ne sais ni lire ni écrire alors
qu'est ce que je peux dire je ne connais
même pas mon nom alors qu'est ce que je
vais parler politique sans avoir jamais
connu l'école kavita était marié à 12
ans percé par d'incessants discours tué
une jeune fille
que vas tu faire en étudiant si tu avais
été un garçon tu aurais pu faire quelque
chose tu ne vas pas devenir magistrat tu
ne vas pas devenir employé fait donc le
travail que font les jeunes filles
[Applaudissements]
encouragés par une association
elles luttent pour suivre des études
sans soutien ni respect elle trouve le
courage de quitter son mari et sa belle
famille et devient journaliste il mon
fils a fait un boulot il a été payé 70
roupies alors qu'on lui avait dit 80
quels établissements là bas qu'elle agit
là il ya dix ans alors pourquoi tu fais
travailler ton fils comment je pourrais
faire autrement
pourquoi tu fais travailler un garçon si
petit c'est interdit par la loi tu dois
attendre qu'il ait au moins 12 ans et se
serait même mieux d'attendre 18 ans il
ya tout le temps des problèmes comme ça
dans les villages c'est sûr mais si on
n'en parle pas on ne risque pas trouver
des solutions
[Musique]
tout comme kavita shanty appartient à
une caste inférieure
j'ai commencé mes études à l'âge de 32
ans
avant j'étais analphabètes je ne
connaissais rien j'ai fait mes études
par moi même j'ai rempli le formulaire
d'écoles primaires et j'ai travaillé ici
à la maison c'est comme ça que je me
suis mise en avant
alors j'ai eu la connaissance j'ai
commencé à sortir et je me suis dit que
ma vie était bidon ce n'était pas
travers le nom de mon mari que j'allais
vivre
alors j'ai pris mon courage à deux mains
et j'ai dit vous ne me passerais plus
vous ne m'insulte aurait plus à l'est de
votre côté j'irai du mien gentil n'a pas
gardé de contacts avec son mari elle
assume seul la charge de ses nombreux
enfants et petits enfants et son métier
d'aujourd'hui celui de journaliste
[Musique]
kavita n'ira chante i et les autres ont
dû se bat pour concrétiser leur rêve
ensemble elles ont créé leur propre
journal kabar la arias la singularité de
l'équipe de rédaction n'être composé que
de femmes toutes membres de castes
inférieures comme les intouchables
[Musique]
on
khabbach la riaa signifie informations
qui font des vagues
le projet existe depuis 2002 grâce au
soutien de l'iran tard un centre de
lutte contre la discrimination des
femmes
dans la région d'uttar pradesh où le
taux d'illettrisme dépasse la moyenne
nationale
ce groupe d'une dizaine de femmes le
combat chaque jour en apportant
l'information à tous et toutes
notre journal n'est pas lié qu'au femme
intouchable
vous allez trouver des informations sur
toutes les classes sociales mais nous
avons donné un peu priorité aux
minorités aux castes inférieures qui
n'ont pas de place ailleurs
cette fois ci c'est bien d'imprimer cnet
allez
mira travaille comme journaliste depuis
six ans épouse mère de cinq filles et
aujourd'hui rédactrice en chef
elle assume toutes ses responsabilités
avec un âne enthousiasmé la différence
avec les autres journaux c'est qu'ils
sont écrits en hindi la langue nationale
notre journal et liées au monde rural et
tout le monde ne sait pas lire le lindy
le nôtre est écrit en gros caractères
dans leur dialecte et des informations
sont juste ce que l'on nous dit on le
retranscris tel quel puis on fait des
commentaires
c'est ça qui nous différencie des autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au quotidien les journalistes parcourent
de longues distances à pied ou en
transport en commun car elles sont
convaincues qu'elles doivent voir de
leurs propres yeux les situations
qu'elles décrivent une conscience
professionnelle que peuvent leur envier
de nombreux journaux qui se contentent
souvent de ce que les responsables
locaux leur liste au téléphone économie
sociale santé politique écologie un
rythme hebdomadaire le journal couvre
tous les domaines
à marée basse personnes vainqueur de
rations alimentaires afin que vous avez
comme terre nous on a cinq lots de terre
80 % des gens ici n'ont pas la carte de
retrait opr tout le monde l'art mais
personne ne peut en profiter
il ne faut pas être de basses castes
surtout pas c'est pour les gens les plus
riches ce n'est pas pour les pauvres
[Musique]
une fois mon a écrit un article
concernant un village là bas il y avait
un mariage dans une famille de castes
supérieures avant le mariage
il n'avait pas évoqué la dot est le jour
du mariage la famille du marié a exigé
une dot
alors la famille de la mariée avec
l'aide des villageois à enfermer les
gens de la famille du marié dans l'école
et ils ont battu notre équipe est allée
enquêter sur place et on a publié cette
histoire à la une
on a appris que le marié avait demandé
un poste de télévision
alors on a titré il veut épouser une
femme ou un téléviseur
alors les gens se sont mis terriblement
en colère commence à nous sommes des
gens de castes supérieures et on se
moque de nous il veut épouser une femme
ou un téléviseur et en plus en première
page
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qu'il se déplace pour leur enquête
les journalistes en profitent pour
vendre elle-même leur journal plus de
300 villages couverts 4300 exemplaire
lui chacun par une dizaine de lecteurs
pas loin de 50 mille lecteurs rien que
pour ce petit groupe de femmes
moi
[Musique]
au début quand on dénonce à quelque
chose dans notre journal
légende défiait ni menacée on a même
reçu des menaces de mort alors on avait
peur
les gens disaient ses journalistes eux
racontent n'importe quoi
alors quand on vendait le journal on
était très gênée on disait le prix est
de 2 roupies et les gens se demandaient
si on faisait ça juste pour l'argent
alors on avait mal au coeur je disais
que notre travail n'était peut-être pas
bien pour être traités de la sorte
maintenant on repense à seilh on se dit
que si on s'était laissée influencer on
aurait fait du surplace elles font un
bon travail
elles vont de maison en maison de
village en village des grands
journalistes eux ne se rendent pas là
bas il reste seulement dans les villes
ici l'information vient de tout petit
endroit est comme ça les fonctionnaires
administratifs sont mis au courant des
problèmes
l'hydro de résoudre ces problèmes
la balle est dans leur camp
hu
[Musique]
confronté aux problèmes de la population
il arrive aux journalistes de faire le
relais avec les administrations comme la
banque locale ou l enquête aujourd'hui
des villageois se sont plaints de
n'avoir pu y effectuer certaines
opérations
comment réagissez vous est ce que c'est
vrai ou pas vous savez il y a beaucoup
de problèmes avec les gens qui ne sont
pas éduqués
personne ne leur explique comment faire
il faudrait que les chefs de village
leur dise avec quels papiers venir moi
je n'ai pas le temps pour cela il
faudrait faire passer l'information
connaissez-vous notre journal bien sûr
je le reçois et je le lis régulièrement
je les apprécie beaucoup
je la connais bien et j'apprécie son
travail bien que ce soit une femme
elle fait sérieusement son travail je
lui ai promis de collaborer autant que
possible je vous redis que j'apporterai
mon aide autant que possible
[Musique]
krabal et des séquences et informations
elles sont ramenées de partout après
tellement de lui alors quand on élit ça
nous fait plaisir
j'aime bien ce journal est la plupart
des gens l'aiment aussi avec ceux ci nos
femmes sont en train d'aller de l'avant
notre société qui étaient opprimés est
en train de s'améliorer le pouvoir de
réflexion et la capacité de nos droits
augmentent les ça avance grâce au
journal on parle de nous à la télévision
dans les infos les journaux autrefois
comme on est des gens de castes
inférieures les gens importants ne nous
faisait pas s'asseoir parmi eux
aujourd'hui ils nous traitent comme des
pères nous propose de nous asseoir sur
des chaises quand on va au poste de
police dans une banque où d'autres
administrations
on nous reconnaît comme journaliste
femme tout le monde nous respecte
beaucoup
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oui
ce qu'on aimerait c'est répandre le
journal dans d'autres districts encore
et pourquoi pas même dans d'autres états
[Musique]
j'ai réussi en luttant et je continue à
le faire
je suis en train de donner la réplique
kavita mirare chantilly et les autres
n'oublierons jamais ce jour où le
premier ministre indien leur décernant
le prix
jamais l'idée vie des consacrant
journalistes les plus remarquables de
l'année
[Musique]